here in Sierra Leone more than 1700
people have died from Ebola since May
when the disease came to this country my
name is Erika Chuck Hayden and I'm here
to meet the people who are trying to
stop this outbreak I started off in a
village called Tam be AMA and then north
of the country a few weeks ago a woman
here died from Ebola and now more than
50 people in this village are in
quarantine can you tell me who you are
what your role is here and what do you
check and how long have these people
been in and why why were these people
put in quarantine how did they come into
contact with well some of them are some
of them even a family member this is
father Francis Sesay he's a priest who
has joined the local Ebola response team
he checks on the villagers to make sure
they're getting all the food and
supplies they need in quarantine
luckily the Tambi amman's all seem
healthy and free of the disease today a
fact that they're eager to demonstrate
just across the road a further nine
people are being held under quarantine
their relative is the woman who died of
Ebola here lab tests confirmed it but in
a village where there isn't a word for
virus not everyone is convinced auntie
Rebecca herself does not believe her
mother died from Ebola I know it's
annoying yeah I know you should know she
will not deny it that is the boiler or
not I mean ask me and I'm working in the
lab will tell you that it is Ebola or
not not Ebola when sorry takes the
opportunity to check on their health
unfortunately everyone seems fine but
there's bad news
during the conversation auntie Rebecca
mentions that the virus has spread to a
nearby village called Maya some of the
residents there are resisting quarantine
explaining that has happened from there
was one house
we are in three people died and I think
they went to another who and they also
three people have died the chief is here
they meet up with the chief and she
explains the situation a woman who lives
in a house where three people died from
Ebola doesn't want to be quarantined
this woman isn't happy with the idea of
being quarantined because she's afraid
of getting sick and being sent far away
for treatment the chief and village
elders struggle to convince her that
it's a necessary measure for her own
health and for the health of her
neighbors and it seems to work we
understand much more on Venus
that road we took today we stopped all
in nine miles does not end of it that
goes as far as to the border the border
between Cyril Leone and Guinea and a
danger here is it is going gradually and
it is taking a kind of a systematic leap
one village moving to the other the
other village moving to the other so the
danger is if it is not curtailed if it
is not stopped at certain points it will
go as fast as points
I thought the danger even know going
back to Guinea and Guinea sending it
back to us because we share the same
boundaries there one thing is clear
though these two villages are on the
right track there's still a lot of work
to be done to stop Ebola from spreading
elsewhere for nature video I'm Erica
check Hayden
you